well earthquakes are a weird kind of
phenomenon in the following sense when
we talk about the theory of plate
tectonics the the working hypothesis is
that it's a smooth motion of the place
that the plates move over geologic time
with predictable rates it's as if
they're kind of a slow movement of
traffic if you will everybody's sort of
moving at a rate that stays constant in
time but obviously earthquakes happen
earthquakes predominantly occur where
the plates interact with one another
along what we call plate boundaries
obviously sometimes those plate
boundaries are sideways like we have in
the San Andreas Fault or in the
earthquake that happened in Haiti
sometimes those boundaries are
compressional like what happened in
Chile or what might happen off the coast
of Seattle and sometimes those
boundaries are what we call extensional
the best example of this would be the
Basin and Range in the western United
States around the longitude of Salt Lake
City going all the way west to the
Sierra
so those three type of boundaries are
described what how the plates inter
interact but earthquakes of course are
not a continuous process by any means
they're really what we call a stick slip
process so while the hypothesis of plate
tectonics so the working model is that
the plates move at a relatively constant
rate at the boundaries they stick and
they slip the boundaries don't move at a
relatively constant rate instead the
boundaries stick and when they stick the
movement of the plates stresses that
boundary and eventually that stress
overcomes the strength of that boundary
and it breaks and that breakage is an
earthquake it's sort of our what we call
a stick slip model or we have other
names for it but that's basically what
happens the problem that we face as
earthquakes seismologists is that
sticking and slipping is almost a
chaotic process not quiet but almost and
so it's very difficult to predict on a
day-to-day basis over geologic time of
course it's very predictable we can
get an idea of where the active plate
boundaries are those plate boundaries of
course are major faults in the earth and
we know where the earthquakes will occur
but because we can't predict the stick
and slip cycle very well of certainly
over human timescales we can't really
get what we call a prediction but
there's a deeper understanding of it
that that allows us to forecast instead
of predict and by forecast I mean well
first of all we know where they occur
because we know what the plate
boundaries are but we can get a sense of
what the probability of an earthquake
might be in two ways one by looking at
the past history and if we have enough
earthquakes we can sort of get a
statistical model of when and
earthquakes might occur and that gives
us some probability and the other is to
actually do a bit of forward modeling
and actually take the plate motions take
a model of the friction along the plate
boundary take a model of how the stress
builds up and sort of predict when and
where or I should say forecast when the
next earthquake might occur and it's
gotten to the point where we could
probably do that over the span of a
decade or two perhaps 30 years to the
extent that we can sort of provide an
actuarial table if you want to go out
and buy insurance in California as a
matter of fact there is such an
actuarial table to help you determine
what your rights are I should say to
help the insurance companies determine
what they're going to charge you of
course we didn't have that for Haiti we
had barely had that for Chile but the
point is were getting better at it so
you know one of the exciting parts of
earthquake seismology is that the better
we get at forecasting earthquakes the
closer we might actually come to a
prediction that is useful on human
timescales
you